if you get hold of two magnets and you
push them you can feel this pushing
between them turned on the other way in
it and they slam together why are they
doing that or how are they doing it your
ass I must say I think that's a
perfectly reasonable question of course
a reason it's an excellent question okay
put the problem that you're asking you
see when you ask why something happens
how does a person answer why something
happens now when you ask for example why
two magnets repel there are many
different levels it depends on you
whether you're a student of physics or
an ordinary person that doesn't know
anything or not if you're somebody who
doesn't know anything at all about all I
can say is that there's a magnetic force
that makes them repel and that you're
feeling that forth I'm not answering
your question but I'm telling you how
difficult the why question is you have
to know what it is that you're permitted
to understand and allow to be understood
and known and what it is you're not well
I have just got that to tell you that's
gonna be one of the things you'll just
have to take as an element in the world
the existence of magnetic repulsion or
electrical electrical attraction
magnetic attraction I can't explain that
attraction in terms of anything else
that's familiar to you so I'm not going
to be able to give you an answer to why
magnets attract each other except to
tell you that they do but I really can't
do a good job any job of explaining
magnetic force in terms of something
else that you're more familiar with
because I don't understand it in terms
of anything else that you're more
familiar with
you
the mathematicians tell you that magnets
field is comprised of lines of force
however they immediately clarify that
these lines are merely abstractions
solely used to represent the forces
surrounding a magnet so what entity
mediates the forces in a magnet in the
alternative if these lines are not real
what is it that is moving when they
assert that the lines travel through the
inside of the magnet the answer is that
the mathematicians pretend to do physics
with absolutely nothing with magic this
is the reason they become a little
uncomfortable when you ask them to
explain how a magnet works in physics
however all phenomena must be and are
mediated by objects we can't do physics
without objects all physicists learn
this principle on the first day of class
those who do physics with abstract
concepts and pretend to move them around
have never taken a course in physics we
begin by establishing that all atoms in
the universe are interconnected under
this proposal the abstract mathematical
lines of force are actually
three-dimensional threads that extend
from one atom to all others when a row
of aligned atom spin they swing the
threads around themselves in the same
direction these threads sweep around the
outside of the magnet and through its
middle here illustrated with red lines
the mathematicians refer to the end of
the magnet where the threads come out as
the north and to the end where the
threads come in as the south however a
magnet is not divided into north and
south it is physically divided into top
and bottom if the threads in the top
half of a magnet swing clockwise
Red's of the bottom half swing
counterclockwise mother nature does not
understand north and south or positive
and negative Mother Nature understands
clockwise and counterclockwise
it is thus that when the south end of a
magnet faces the north end of another
the threads on the top half of the south
side swing clockwise while those of its
bottom half swing counterclockwise
likewise the threads on the top half of
the north end swing clockwise whereas
the threads on the bottom half swing
counterclockwise when the threads at the
top of the south side come down they
drag the threads at the top of the north
side which are coming up conversely the
threads at the bottom half of the south
side come up and drag the threads at the
bottom of the north side as they come
down
to visualize this mechanism think of two
people skipping ropes close to each
other
the Rope of one comes down and that of
the other goes up the ropes pull on each
other the closer one magnet is to
another the more threads that intervene
in the entire process and a stronger the
pull of one magnet on the other if we
turn one of the magnets 180 degrees
sideways nothing changes the same
pattern develops and we continue to have
attraction however if we turn the same
magnet a hundred and eighty degrees from
front to end in a north-south direction
now the top threads and bottom threads
of both magnets are clashing against
each other think of two people skipping
ropes against each other the ropes will
push each other away
it is these rapidly moving walls of
threads which create attraction and
repulsion between magnets now you can
explain how a magnet works to your
friends
you
you
my name is Bill Gates and I'm a very
famous nobody and I want to keep it that
way today hopefully all of you came here
not to ask for my autograph not to ask
for my credentials hopefully all of you
came here to ask for an explanation of
some phenomenon of physics and maybe
that's what we should ask all these
people people like Stephen Hawking or
even Einstein on the street something
you know you don't ask him for his
autograph you ask him for an explanation
you don't care who the guy is can he
explain some phenomena physics
rationally that's the issue that's what
we're going to do today I'm gonna be
explaining today one phenomena
explain how magnet works how a magnet
attracts another from a distance and how
it pushes it away explain the mechanism
give you a physical mechanism that you
can take to your friends to your
family's head yeah I can tell you how
how magnet attracts another I chose this
subject because it's like the it's the
test of fire it's called the lion's paw
test lion's paw in 17th century it was a
mathematician as being this Bernoulli
and he had a problem he could not solve
and so he sent it to different mines in
Europe innocently solve this problem for
me one of the answers came back from
merry old England and it was anonymous
so Bernoulli got it back he said uh this
is the right solution and he says he was
sent this he said ah we recognized the
lion by his Paul thus the lion's paw
test and he was referring to Newton
since the guy who could solve this
problem from him
and so it's called the lion's paw test
for mathematics and this is the lion's
paw test for physics physicists you know
we learned this on the first week of
physics if you don't know you can't
explain in a rational way how magnet
attracts another you haven't taken your
first course of physics now you know you
know someone might come and say look you
know I've got a degree in physics from I
don't know Oxford University well yeah
that's fine but you know it's like does
that make you a physicist because you
got a degree let's say you're running
the circus right and you put an ad in
the newspaper wanted tightrope walkers
and this guy shows up
you're a tightrope walker yeah okay
there's a rope walk it so the guy gets
up there and it starts me it takes one
step new bolts
okay he tries again takes a step
followed he does this ten times and he
always falls and you say you know I got
a show to run I thought you said you
were a tightrope walker why yeah I've
got a degree from Ringling Brothers
Barnum and Bailey Circus yeah your
credentials are very impressive but you
can't walk a rope so you're not a
tightrope walker this is something
similar we've done this on the first
week of physics class if you don't know
this then you haven't taken your first
physics course you might think you're a
physicist you might have the degree from
the best University on the planet but
this is the test
fire can you explain how I may need
attracts another and that's what we're
gonna do today I'm gonna show you how
Mannie doesn't what the mechanism is
okay but before that we have to find out
what physics is what is physics about
physics first and foremost requires an
object you can opt in physics an object
imagine we take I brought it here magic
wand and we erase all the matter from
the universe you take all the galaxies
all the stars all the planets all the
gases every atom there's nothing there
there's nothing well there's not much
going on in such an empty universe you
know what's what's happening what do you
see him there's nothing now in order
that see something happening you need to
have some kind of object and they're
moving doing something flashy you can't
do it with nothing so let's put
something in there put lovely
can we do physics with love then just
pour some love in there and have to
crash move around do things rotate oh we
can't do physics we love why because
it's a concept
I can't move love I can't talk about the
motion of love maybe of a heart but not
of love okay so let's put something up
let's put energy can you do physics with
energy is there such a thing as energy
that we can move transfer kick around
turn into mass is there such a thing
energy is defined as the capacity to do
work it's a concept I can't move
energy around because there's nothing
there to move around is defined as a
property of objects it's a concept I
can't do physically love and can fizzes
with energy you need an object so what
is an object turns out in the last
200,000 years since maybe send it from
the trees I guess no one has defined
what an object is nobody knows what an
object is not a single book of physics
then you go to high school you go to
college not a single book of physics
begins by telling you what an object is
here we have the first rule of physics
it says you can't do physics without an
object and no one has ever defined but
now I'll do this so we have to do this
before we can do any physics it's the
first word any physicist has to define
and we're going to find that is that
which has shape that's what an object is
for the purposes in physics now you
won't find that definition in the
dictionary if you look at any dictionary
anywhere in the world an object is
defined as that which we can touch or
see the problem with that definition of
circular we can't use it in physics
something else has to do
the touching something else has to do
the scene you need up an object to
define the word object so it's circular
you can't use that this definition
stands on its own
you don't need to touch through anything
you don't need to run a proof and
experiment if an object a shape if it's
the only object in the universe it has
shaped he qualifies as the word under
the word object anything else that
doesn't have shape falls under concepts
you have concepts we have objects so
we're going to be doing physics with
objects here what we're gonna do is
explain magnets you have two pieces of
metal context of note that's all this is
the entire system and I put them
together and you stick
magic magic that very few people can
explain they said how does it happy now
it happens from the I can feel they're
pulling right there anyone can try it
any time if I turn them around
I get the opposite effect I can't put
him together they push each other way I
have two horseshoes they're made up
Middleton and I'll do it here so it
won't fall but you'll see that you know
[Music]
there's no magic here so here we have
magic and here we don't have there's
some qualitative difference here
something different between this set and
this set and hopefully it's mediated by
an object overall crazy where we do it
with we're gonna do nothing
concepts is a concept holding these two
you know you shaved or or of course you
shape the magnets together what's
holding this there's nothing there
something's different between you this
set of this and we have to explain that
therefore what is the difference you
know are we just gonna describe and say
wow they stick together north attract
south what does that mean I could said
why attracts X have I explained the
mechanism no I need to explain the
physical
mechanism how something attracts
something else from distance it's
already pulling on me right there so
this is what we've been trying to
explain what's happening and what we
have to do is identify the object that's
doing that magic now these two sets
these two sets of these two sets
they're both surrounded by objects and
object is that which has shape now both
of these objects are surrounded by air
some people don't realize it but air is
an object it's not a concept air is made
out of atoms which turn into molecules
Oh - and some other stuff we call it air
you might say well what is the shape of
air I mean if an object is that one's
has shape and I'm saying that air is an
object and what is the shape of air you
might ask that you show you the shape of
air at least on our planet this is the
safe of air air covers our planet it's
made out of atoms it looks like a shell
that's what air looks like here on our
planet but you can give it any shape you
want you can take a balloon blood could
be a sphere astronaut takes the balloon
to outer space pinches the balloon and
the blog comes out some the irregular
blob comes out if you could color code
it you can see it is it others there it
looks like this blob so the question is
not what is the shape of the blob the
question is does it have shape it's a
yes or no type of question you know
energy this energy have shape we're not
asking what is the shape of energy is
does it have shape the answer is clearly
now its concept concepts do not have
shape on the other hand you know objects
do have shape and here air has shape it
can take this
that you want you can mold it into
anything you but see these two systems
they're both surrounded by air
you know both surround so air is not the
the one producing the magic there's some
other object that we cannot see here
besides air that's doing this magic
that's what we can identify so what is
it that we want explain we want to
explain several properties that need two
magnets we have to explain every one of
these properties we cannot just explain
you one and say oh we discovered how it
magnets work we have to explain each one
of these properties let's go with the
first one this is a wire and the
conventional wisdom is that we have
electrons the negative little balls
there they're flowing and just by the
flow of these electrons it creates
what's known as a magnetic fields those
rings you see around then that wire okay
everybody see that so just by the flow
of electrons this is you to punish you
can receive today a field is created
this field extends beyond the wire it's
a halo that surrounds the wire you got
close to that you know you can put a
magnet close to that just like this one
and you can pull the wire without
touching you on some point it gets close
enough to the halo that the wires pulled
in so it's something physical there you
know this is not nothing this is
something that ring around them so we
have to explain what is that right any a
theory that talks about magnetism has to
explain that magic
what is that halo that's
Oh higher next property we have to
explain these are all observations that
we've seen for many years we turned the
wire that wire and you can see that this
is called the left hand rule this is the
direction of that field called a
magnetic field and he's showing you know
which way that field is pointing at any
around the wire but when you have one
side of the wire against the other
they're pointing in the opposite
direction if this one from your point of
view this one is counterclockwise the
fingers here are clockwise they're
opposite once you turn down the wire
around see if you go with your hand all
around when this hand is over here is
it's facing like this and it's on the
other side is facing like that the
fingers curled in the opposite direction
so you have to explain you know if the
magnetic field here is clockwise here
it's kind of like I said that's another
property we will have to explain you
cannot get away from and say well I
cannot explain this but I'll explain
some other you have to explain each one
of these properties and here we have
another property if we coil that same
wire sufficient winding you will find
that the field goes through the inside
and comes out the outside they blend
they turn into this flow and it goes
around the coil goes on the inside of
the coil and comes on the outside of the
coil that's what we will have to explain
this phenomena as well this property
okay and we have to explain how that
coil turns into a magnet itself the
magnet has the same property as a coil
the field goes through the center here
and out the outside that's the direction
of the
okay we're talking about the direction
of the feet if you go through the center
of the magnet comes out on the outside
you call the north side word comes out
the south side where it comes in
direction for the feet okay you're at
put two tanks army tanks and the wheels
of the tank you know there are mirror
images in this case went winning against
the other and this is exactly the flow
of the field it goes from the center of
the magnet and out the outside of the
magnet so this is mimicking this is a
illustration we just saw it in so now we
have presented here's another way of
looking at it you can have two wheels
turning in the opposite direction and
they'll have no problem in scrolling
against each other they don't like each
other
you just hit each other like push each
other away but we can't produce it here
but if this one were to go clockwise
would this set of gears move you got one
coming down the other one coming up they
get stuck there's no motion they hate
each other
they attract each other as long as we
have in the opposite direction they
don't like each other but the other way
they lock into each other you can't move
either gear we've seen there's another
property we have two wires parallel
wires the attraction the the current is
running in the same direction in both of
them if it runs in the same direction
the wires attract each other if current
runs in opposite direction when it comes
the other one goes they don't like it
they push each other away we have to
explain each one of these
characteristics properties of wires and
magnets in of coils can't abide any of
them he who cannot explain each step
here has not explained how this world
works and here's another one we have two
wires and we sprinkle
iron filings around them - where's my
current if the current runs in the same
direction it runs into your eyes through
both wires this is the pattern that's
formed by the iron filings contrast this
with the wires running current in
opposite directions and you get if you
pour the the iron families around and
you get this pattern okay and again you
can see that there's a pattern very
similar to what we just saw with the two
gears going in opposite directions they
don't like each other and this is
something similar this one goes this
four this one goes that way that seemed
person who gives you very different than
when you just saw a minute ago versus
that way current running in the same
direction current running in opposite
directions those are how the iron
filings get sprinkle that's the pattern
WC we have to explain each one of these
phenomena they talk about lines of force
they say the lines of force make up the
magnetic field what is the problem the
problem is that they say that the
magnetic lines of force are not real
again they're doing physics with nothing
they're saying we use the lines of force
to illustrate let them take them
seriously they're not there so we end up
saying well then what is the field if we
have a field that's producing your
physical phenomena physical insulin a
physical force and then we say well yeah
and we can explain this with lines of
force and then we say but the lines of
force don't really exist or not there
then one would have you learn we haven't
learned much we don't know what's
causing it still so they say magnetic
fields are not real entities in 3d space
they are a dressed man's artifice it's
just a trick that they use to explain
magnetic fields and here's another one
says there are no real lines of force
field lines are simply a mathematical
construct that's what they that's what
they're teaching so you know the
question is how are we producing a
physical phenomenon with you know
abstractions we got problem there we can
only do physics with objects these lines
had better be real we just need to find
out what they are and there's another
problem with that and that's that they
say that the that they talk about
magnetic flux that something is moving
in there but they say flex does not
actually flow from north to south pole
or flow anywhere for that matter as
magnetic flux is a static region around
the magnet in which the magnetic force
exists in other words magnetic flux does
not flow or move at all
so we have a flux that is not flexing a
flow that is not flowing and this is
Ramon
you know why it's wrong unpair a 19th
century
investigative guy who did put a few
experiments with magnetism and
electricity you discover that magnetic
lines are produced by moving charges so
we have something that's moving that's
creating something that static that's
what they you personally want to give
you and that impression is wrong and we
know this because of the following these
are iron filings that are sprinkled in
water and now they put a magnet in there
and you can see can little by little how
the little iron filings are being
collected around the magnet something is
drawing them there something had better
be moving you cannot talk about a static
field if the iron filings are being
collected
one by one close to the magnet something
is moving this field is in motion in
other words that the field has something
that is dynamic within it something that
is moving in it otherwise you can't
produces its slowly collecting one
particle at a time okay so we have to
just figure out what these lines of
force are and in order to do that we're
going to contrast quantum mechanics
against what I'm gonna be proposing
today one of mechanics is a world of
discrete particles and what we're
proposing in exchange is that all atoms
in the universe are interconnected
every atom in the universe is connected
to all others there's the distinction
and here I listed it for you this is
quantum mechanics discrete particles and
Universal particles that each one is
independent and here we have what I call
the Rope hypothesis and you'll see that
why the name for that in a minute all
particles in the universe are
interconnected now there's a difference
between these two in the sense that you
cannot produce the force of pull with
discrete particles you have two
particles this is the entire universe
how does this one get this one move from
a distance if there's nothing else in
the universe except these two particles
the only way this we can get this one to
move if they're somehow connected by an
elongated extended object then you can
get this one you can rationalize how
this one gets the swing boat you can
pull on it with something in between if
there's absolutely nothing in between
you cannot produce pull and quantum has
a problem with the force of pull they
cannot explain quantum mechanics the
people who you know subscribe to this
theory you cannot explain the force of
pull you will never hear
Brava there's no no way to explain
gravity under quantum mechanics you can
only explain gravity if everything is
connected and you can explain why the
uncommon galaxy is being drawn to the
Milky Way galaxy because there is a
connection there otherwise we're dealing
with angels with spirits with ghosts if
there's nothing there we have to do with
magic okay so that's our starting point
we're saying there's a difference there
so the question is what are these lines
that you see there what are what are
these interconnections and we're saying
that that's a rope like mechanism it's
got to do with light this is the
standard view that you learn in high
school in college of lightning it's an
electromagnetic wave they just send this
thing out which is not a thing because I
don't you see it well here but these are
all little arrows painted arrows and you
say well what is what is the object what
is the median
what is the entity that's it and they
say it's nothing it's the undulation of
nothing that's what you get that's what
you'll see that's what you'll be taught
oh we're saying that this is really a
rope rope light mechanism we have two
threads twine threads and that's what is
in connect that inter connecting each
one of these atoms here we're saying all
those lines are a rope like DNA like
entity that connects any two halves what
is light
light is the portion of that rope here
you see the Rope twirly and we're saying
that's what light is it's the torsion of
a rope whereas this one is just a
mathematical construct just the nothing
bunch of arrows that they paint in they
say well the wave moves you listen this
doesn't tell you what physical mechanism
is producing light this one is saying
there is a physical mediator it's a rope
like mechanism
that binds any two atoms this is the
famous quantum jump they say this is how
light is generated from an atom an atom
a little that has a little center part
called a proton at the edge you have an
electron the electron jumps back and
forth and when it falls to a lower
energy level a stream of particles
called photons comes out and when it
rises to an energy left and an energy
level it absorbs a stream of photons so
the atom just pushes photons out and
pulls them in constantly this is another
version this is with the wave the atom
again pumps back the electron comes back
and forth and a wave comes out goes off
to nowhere and we're saying these two
images are wrong this is the the
incorrect way of looking at what we're
of major what we're saying is that there
are two atoms here we chose two atoms
they're interconnected by a rope and as
they expand and contract they torque the
rope light is that torsion is that
signal a longer loop that's what we're
proposing in exchange how does this
produce what does this have to do with
magnetism we have two atoms and we're
seeing you're connected by a rope and
the Rope one of the threads comes out
loose it starts twirling around it
starts twirling around what happens when
you have more than one atom we have a
row of atoms well then we have a wall of
threads going around okay so we have a
series of atoms they're all connected by
this rope one of the threads comes out
loose starts twirling around we have a
row of atoms several the threads come
out loose in the swing the threads
around
well the first thing we get explained
with this just so far with this setup
did what I showed earlier here we we
need Lane this field that goes around
the wire instead of electron flow those
little little beads moving along the
wire we have the atoms the electrons
spinning the threads around the wire so
now we have simulated this in a
different format
we don't have electron flow what we have
is the turning of atoms they're spinning
and you're spinning the threads around
themselves that those threads those
lines of force are threads and we're
saying these are physical threads they
produce physical effects so we have at
least mimicked this in a different way
we're saying there's no flow of
electrons what we have is the turning of
ABS feeder turn clockwise or counter
clockwise doesn't matter but whichever
way they turn they turn the whole wall
of threads okay second part we're going
to explain what happens when we coil the
wire take this wire and turn it around
and now recorded it to another words
what we've done is this right this
direction and the ones at the top have
but different directions the ones at the
bottom just by turning here they were
like that right with the MIT my thumb
will be pointing this way but the
current should be like this right I'll
forget about this thumb here they should
go like that well what happens when you
turn them around will they're in
opposite directions you see that the
fingers are in opposite directions so
the ones at the top of the ones that are
colored violet are going in the opposite
direction of the ones at the bottom
they're in opposite directions simply by
curving the wire now they're spinning
the threads in this direction the other
ones are spinning in the opposite
direction but look at the interesting
part they run the force right through
the center you know if one is spinning
this way and the other one spinning that
way the force is through this
of the court and that's what I'm showing
here okay so we now have explained the
second part but in other words we at
least have been able to simulate what we
see here where we coil where we coil the
wire okay coil it just give it one coil
and this side is now gonna be turning
opposite that side we have at least
mimicked that so so far we have
explained these two phenomena okay let's
see we can plane the third one now we
take the this coil and we have several
of these coils and think of this as a
cross section it's a coil but we put the
coil in half so what you're seeing is
half of the coil the top ones spinning
in this case it's clockwise here it's
counterclockwise it should be opposite
the force is through the center the
force is going in this direction under
the current labeling that we use this is
the north part of the coil or the magnet
and this is the south part the code the
the force goes in through the back
that's the south part comes out the
front which is the north part okay so
that's what we're seeing here and this
mimics or simulates quite well the coil
that we saw earlier the force runs
through the center it turns out the
outside this may mean exactly that you
know what we observe in the laboratory
okay it's mimicking that it's not this
way that's why the X is there it's it
you know blends together and now the
force goes through the center of the
coil comes out the outside so we mimic
this as well we simulated these three
properties of quartz so far if we have
the atoms spinning and moving the coils
the threads through the
coming out here from south to north we
can see what the float looks like inside
a magnet if we were to sprinkle iron
filings around it it would take that
pattern exactly the pattern shown there
the bottom one goes counterclockwise the
top ones go clockwise in this case and
that also simulates what we saw earlier
which is this where the coil turns into
the magnet if we were to sprinkle iron
filings on top of a magnet or on top of
the coil these are the patterns that you
would get with either one of these two
mechanisms okay without the flow of
current what you did is simply Adams
turning in place swinging the threads
that connect them and now the question
is you know how does this produce
attraction and repulsion how do we get
from this mechanism that I just
explained to float the turning of atoms
which swings Reds around real threats
those famous lines of force that causes
some kind of push we turn that now into
attraction and repulsion how does it
make it work let's begin by showing the
simple mechanism are you sure it here
there's a little device I made last
moment I thought it'd be interesting and
very crude device I'm certainly in newer
generation will come up with something
better than this how something automatic
so we got to leave something for the new
generations and what this does it's it
simulates it simulates a rope jumping
and your jumping room just give you rope
and that's what it does very simple for
a thing it turns around and it skips so
in this case from your point of view
they're both going counterclockwise
right now what happens if one of these
comes down while the other one tries to
come up well if they intend to grab
they tend to pull on the other one on
the other hand if we send one clockwise
this woman is still going
counterclockwise they tend to clasp and
push each other away they don't like
each other so it's not the same thing
for two things to go in this direction
and clash then for both of them to go in
the same direction one pulling on the
other and that's with this simulator
okay let me now show it here we have two
brothers I'll call them Axel and rod and
excellently the blue guy he is spinning
his rope counterclockwise and rod is
also spinning his make it tangle they're
too close together so what happens when
this guy's rope comes up it grabs it
clashes it picks up the rope of rod as
his comes down so if they're both going
in the same direction they got a problem
in the sense that they interfere with
each other one pulls and the other
there's there's the mechanism of pool
Deborah in explaining how about push
that's bull now we're going to look at
push we turn axel around and now the
ropes collide they hit up against each
other they don't like each other
something we have push now notice this
pretty much resembles the pattern we saw
earlier of iron friends sprinkled around
to current-carrying wires here we have
the two wires they're both moving in the
same direction
they're both counterclockwise they're
spinning all the threads in the same
direction okay and as this one comes up
and this one's comes down they pull on
each other
the closer the wires are together the
more threads that
the more threats that intervene the
faster the stronger the pull and you
will notice well maybe you won't notice
it just by trying to magnets but they've
done it in the lab where you can see the
speed it's exponential at first the
magnet starts attracting your gluten
they go faster faster and faster and
faster as they get closer together why
because as they get closer more threads
intervene for more atoms they're closer
together more more threads grab onto
each other but push they're going in the
opposite direction they don't like each
other so they push each other way closer
they are the more atoms that intervene
the more threads and intervene the heart
of the push the farther they are out the
slower it gets why because fewer at
fewer threads are involved here we have
a simulation of both of these here we
show how they attract by moving kind of
illustrate their how a magnet is
attracted to another we turn the magnet
around and as long as we turn it in the
same direction and we still have North
against South that it's called
there still will be attraction but what
happens when we turn weatherman is
completely around well now they don't
like each other little hit each other
and they push each other away you see
that so let's look at that again the
attraction they're both moving in the
same direction one collects the other
pulls it whether you turn the magnet in
you know rotate it as long as you keep
the same face nothing will change there
still will be attraction that's what we
see and that's what we're simulating
with the threads in order for the other
to be push extra repulsion you have to
turn it completely around we have north
against north or south against south now
the threads are going in the opposite
and now they're hitting each other and
pushing each other away so we have
simulated what we see with magnets where
the threads no magic just threads that
we can't see that's all here's the
pattern
of two wires carrying current in the
same direction and we can see that here
you know we see the same patterns we see
the circular patterns are formed by it
the closer the two wires are together
the the threads and come pass both wires
and so we if we were to sprinkle iron
filings around these two wires we would
get that batter that's the pattern you
expect because they're moving in the
same direction what happens if we turn
one of the wires around or change the
current flow well now you get something
like this you get the flow of current
that flow the threads in this case right
maybe like this they don't like each
other
and if you sprinkled iron filings on
those two wires you're gonna get that
batter so again this tends to point to
the flowing of threats the movement does
the scanning of threads here we have the
four corners of a magnet I don't know if
you see the blue the red lines in the
center that's supposed to be like the
center of the magnet I'm trying to give
you a 3d image there as best as possible
the south side the threads go in north
side the threads come out they're
flowing all around the magnet if we were
to look at just the square magnet
through the center through the center
here right that's the center here the
threads are moving through the center
coming out over and into the center
again so it's like the paint that you
just saw a minute ago one tank is moving
that way the other tank is moving that
way okay so that's what you're seeing
there and and again those are the if you
sprinkle iron filings around the magnet
that's the pattern you would get you
even that's the classical pattern of
a regular magnet we're saying
essentially that a magnet is divided
between not north and south it's divided
between top and bottom any magnets why
we can't find a monopole they've been
trying to look for a monopole for years
there's no way you need to to make a
magnet you can't do it one why because
the top once the threads are moving
around the magnet going through the
center and colliding against the ones
that are going in the opposite direction
at the bottom so I can cut this magnet
and - I'm gonna get the same result no
matter how many times I chop it up I'll
never get a monopole because on the top
they move in one direction on the bottom
in the opposite direction
a magnet is not divided between north
and south is divided between top and
bottom up and down now that makes sense
now we can explain if we put another
magnet here or something that unites
here we explain why magnetic rejects the
other one you can see what's happening
here between the magnets this is the
north side that's a south side that's
the yes there I guess you can see how
they're classy the the threads are
moving in this direction at the top in
this direction at the bottom inter
colliding against the threads coming
from the bottom on the others magnet
that's why they don't like each other
they either attract in this case they're
attracting and and you can see that
right here where the juncture is well
two are coming in the other ones are
coming down they're grabbing on to each
other that's what they do that's why
they attract the threads are moving here
this way and here they're moving that
way well what happens when we turn the
bank get around
well now you can see here Hawaii they
don't like it only did just turn the
magnet around but it's the physical
threads that produced that there had
better be an object there or we're all
crazy with this we can explain how
magnets attract each other in both
elections when we when the magnets are
facing this case red against blue
they're moving in the same direction one
comes up pulls and pulls it in
if we rotate it sideways no change you
can see that the same effect happens in
order for them to repel you have to have
turn the magnet completely around so
that's facing the other direction now
the collide so it's the threads that
underlie this we here we have the hosts
and the generously provided their castle
where we are performing this physics
conference and we want to kind of reward
them with a little something at least
from my part so that you can play you
have to handle this one and he handles
that
[Laughter]
thank you I usually see